TUCKER CARLSON IS COMING UP NEX
NEXT.
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT" AND
HAPPY PRESIDENTS' DAY.
HE MAY HAVE NOTICED AN
ACCELERATING CYCLE IN WASHINGTON
LATELY.
HERE'S WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE.
THE PERMANENT CLASS HATES
DONALD TRUMP.
THEY ATTACK THEM AS RACIST,
CRIMINAL, A FOREIGN SPY LOOKING
TO DESTROY AMERICA.
TRUMP, BECAUSE HE WATCHES MORE
ABOUT TELEVISION THAN IS
HEALTHY, SEES THESE ATTACKS AND
RESPONDS WITH HOSTILE TWEETS.
HIS CRITICS POINT OUT THOSE
TWEETS AS EVIDENCE THAT TRUMP IS
EVERY BIT AS BAD AS HE SAYS HE
WAS AND SO ON.
THE LATEST INSTALLMENT OF THE
SAGA TOOK PLACE OVER THE
WEEKEND.
CNN POLITICAL PANELIST WARNED
THAT TRUMP'S CRITICISM OF THE
MEDIA IMPROVES HE'S A WOULD-BE
DICTATOR.
>> DISCREDITING MUELLER,
DISCREDITING WHAT COME OUT OF
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT,
DISCREDITING THE PRESS OF WHAT
MUELLER DOES, THIS IS WHAT
SPLITS A COUNTRY APART AND THIS
IS THE BEGINNINGS OF MANY OTHER
COUNTRIES IT IS THE BEGINNINGS
OF ENOUGH AUTHORITARIAN RULE.
>> Tucker: THAT'S KIND OF
HILARIOUS.
THE IRONY OF COURSE IS THAT HE
SPENT MUCH OF HIS OWN CAREER IN
GOVERNMENT NOT SIMPLY
CRITICIZING REPORTERS BY
ACTIVELY LYING TO THEM, AS IS
CUSTOM.
WAS AT THE BEHAVIOR OF A
DESPERATE?
PRETTY FUNNY.
PAUSE AND CONSIDER THIS A
LET'S SEE IF YOU REALLY WEREN'T
AUTHORITARIAN AND WANTED TO
WEAKEN AMERICAN DEMOCRACY AND
OPPOSE AN OLIGARCHY ON THE
COUNTRY.
HOW WOULD YOU GO ABOUT DOING
THAT?
YOU'D PROBABLY START PATROLLING
WHAT PEOPLE SAY AND THINK.
IT'S A DISSENTED FROM THE
MANDATED ORTHODOX THAT THEY
CONSIDER UNAUTHORIZED IDEAS, YOU
TARGET THEM AND SHAME THEM ON
SOCIAL MEDIA, HE SHUT THEM DOWN
AND MET PUBLIC AND GET THEM
FIRED FROM THEIR JOBS, YOU MAKE
SURE EVERYBODY IS AFRAID TO
DISAGREE WITH YOU.
AFTER THAT, YOU WOULD WORK TO
DISARM THE POPULATION.
TAKE THEIR GUNS AWAY, THAT WAY
THEY BE ENTIRELY DEPENDENT ON
YOU FOR THEIR SAFETY, NOT TO
MENTION UNABLE TO RESIST YOUR
PLANS FOR THEM.
JUST TO MAKE SURE YOU QUELLED
ALL OPPOSITION, HE WOULD
SYSTEMATICALLY TARGET ANY
INSTITUTION THAT MIGHT OPPOSE OR
PUT BRAKES ON YOUR POWER.
YOU WOULD BE ESPECIALLY
CONCERNED ABOUT CHURCHES, THE
FAMILY, AND INDEPENDENT
BUSINESSES.
YOU'D BE CERTAIN TO UNDERMINE
AND CROSS THOSE USING LAWS AND
RELENTLESS PROPAGANDA.
DESPITE ALL THAT, IF ELECTION
RESULTS DIDN'T GO YOUR WAY,
YOU'D USE AN ENTRENCHED
BUREAUCRACY TO NEUTER ANY LEADER
YOU HAD IT HANDPICKED YOURSELF.
YOU'D BE SHAKEN BY AN ELECTION
LIKE THAT AND WOULD RESULT IN
NEVER AROUND OF VIOLENT AGAIN.
TO MAKE SURE OF THAT, YOU'D
WORKED TIRELESSLY TO REPLACE THE
OLD AND I'M GRATEFUL POPULATION
WITH THE NEW AND MORE OBEDIENT O
WITH THE NEW AND MORE OBEDIENT E
WITH THE NEW AND MORE OBEDIENT .
THAT'S WHAT YOU DO.
SOUND FAMILIAR?
WE ARE NOT TALKING ABOUT
DONALD TRUMP.
FOR ALL OF HIS FAULTS, TRUMP
ISN'T DOING ANY OF THAT.
OUR RULING CLASS IS, AND THAT'S
WHAT ALL THESE ISSUES ARE REALLY
ABOUT.
THE SPEECH CODES, THE CALLS FOR
GUN CONTROL, THE DEMANDS FOR
UNLIMITED MASS IMMIGRATION.
NONE OF THAT IS DESIGNED TO HELP
YOU.
NONE OF THAT WILL MAKE YOU
HAPPIER OR MORE PROSPEROUS.
THAT'S NOT THE POINT.
THE POINT IS TO MAKE YOU MORE